hello and welcome to another episode of
steampunks the GameSpot show we go
through the steam new releases and tell
you what's good that week this week I'm
Edmund Tran just what have you been
playing this week all right I played one
game in particular this week that I was
really into but was incredibly
complicated called lobotomy corporation
so the best way I can quickly describe
this one is that it's kind of like a
fallout shelter and SCP containment
breach had a baby wow this must be a
very popular game it is this company has
come up with a plan where they can breed
an energy source out of monsters you've
got a series of employees XCOM style
that you hire and you can level them and
equip them with things that you buy
later on with said energy sauce but
basically there are four different ways
to interact with these abnormalities and
when you first get them you don't know
anything about them so you need to trial
and error using different ways of
interacting with them to hopefully
figure out the one that works or the
option that will probably end up
happening which is you piss them off and
they get out and then your entire
facility goes under because your
employees get murdered or everyone
panics so this game takes place on a day
to day basis so you're playing out each
day - starting out for example with
control you move on to like the the
technology facility and then into the
security facility there are always a
little random attacks that can happen
where dudes just born in your base and
you need to take them out and like
fallout shelter yeah and hopefully not
die there's also meltdown so every
single time even if you're just managing
an abnormality every single time you
enter their room you increase the chance
of having an overall meltdown so you
don't necessarily have to end the day at
any particular point it tells you when
you've attained the energy you need for
that day and then you can just end the
day then if you want the monsters are
actually really interesting there's like
terrifying little ones that look like
dolls there's ones that's just static
filling a room and you can zoom in and
see how they're interacting with your
employees one of the things that also
makes the game harder is the
monsters are very particular about what
they need and what they want and the
things that will set them off for
example they can get attached to one
employee and if that employee then goes
off to take care of another monster
they'll just die instantly so the stuff
like that you need to remember and when
you end up with managing dozens of
different monsters and containment
facilities it can be a little tricky
it's extremely confusing it's also all
translated English is not the primary
language of this game so the story can
be slightly hard to understand and more
of the 30 to 40 odd pages of tutorial
notes make this a very hard strategy
game to grasp but it's so enjoyable when
you do get into it and when you turn
like a really scary
unknown monster into a familiarity who's
like a reliable energy source lobotomy
corporation is 25 bucks or just kind of
on the high range of games we tend to
look at but with a hundred plus hours of
gameplay if you're super into it and you
just want to keep expanding and
expanding and expanding I think it's
really worth it and the amount of unique
things they ought to discover and do
make it kind of a strategy players dream
so I would recommend it
all right so interesting and good
accurately represents the game I played
this week which is spy party so spy
party is a game designed by Chris hecka
who was a super interesting guy look him
up he's done a bunch of incredible stuff
and though this has just come out on
Steam early access the game has actually
been in sort of active early access
development for almost ten years and
I've been in the beta since about 2012
or so so this is a 1v1 asymmetric
multiplayer game where one person plays
the role of a spy at sort of a
high-class party shindig thing and has
to discreetly achieve a bunch of
objectives within the time limit and one
person is a sniper who's looking inwards
at the building from the outside and has
one bullet to take out the spy with so
obviously the challenge here is that the
sniper is trying to work out which of
the party guests is actually another
player
these platters can be pretty busy and a
lot of characters in them you can only
see so much at a time so it's a really
hard job there are a few tells you can
use to narrow it down for example
despite might have an objective to speak
a code word to a double agent
the sniper can unrealistically sort of
hear this but it means that when you do
hear it you can immediately narrow down
all the candidates that aren't in like a
conversation circle acting like you
would your playing a normal game and
with no movement and so with strafing
and stuff really give it away this was
what a lot of pressure playing as a spy
because you can actually see the snipers
laser pointer pointing into the room so
if they're looking at you there's like a
lot of pressure to just play it cool
yeah not [ __ ] up I really love this game
and it's had sort of AI dedicated player
base throughout its entire development
because the concept is so interesting
and unique it's fun to watch as much as
it is to play it's $24.99 which is again
is a little bit more pricey but it's
really really damn good it's probably
one of my favourite games we've seen in
the show so far I implore everyone to at
least give it a shot
all right well we've subjet and brought
in eddie makuu who's gonna talk to us
about team's biggest new release this
week probably for better or worse and it
is called radical heights it's a very
radical game with a very radical name
this is the next game from boss key
which is the studio that made
lawbreakers so you know founded by cliff
Kaczynski the guy can created Gears of
War so this is a battle royale game
similar kind of structure to what you
might be used to hundred players one map
Last Man Standing wins but this is a
very very early access game they're
calling it extreme early access really
axis and the whole thing is like it's
80s right yeah so it's like an eighties
like game show theme their quirk is that
you collect cash that you keep even if
you lose the game there's like a Wheel
of Fortune type thing that'll pop up
throughout the game and other kind of
dynamic elements like that that you can
stand in front of for a period of time
to unlock either you know weapons or
items are collectibles things like that
but while you're doing so you're very
vulnerable so that's kind of you know
the trade-off the other thing that is
worth mentioning is that you know it's
very much unfinished there's a lot of
just missing textures and when you're
riding a bike oh so that's the other
thing BMX biking is like a big part of
this game because that was big in the
80s one of the things you can do is run
around and you know shoot people while
you're riding a bike except for the
shooting elements are not like animated
into the game you just see the bullets
flying out of nowhere so on a scale of
wackiness where pubsey is the lowest and
4/9 is the highest this is kind of like
off-the-charts i think it is yeah it's
the same kind of you know variety of
weapons that you might find you know
pistols assault rifles sniper rifles and
then all kinds of items you know the
standard things like grenades but also
some wacky or things like there's a
there's an item that clones you so if
there's someone nearby you can toss this
item and it'll just create a clone
version of yourself so there's some nice
I guess little like elements of variety
in there it's a free game so you can
just jump right in and try it in the
very last match that I played I got down
to the top ten and that's I think when
most battle royale games really like
shine because that's when you're at you
know it's the most tense part of any
match and that's when I have the most
fun with this you either can purchase
things with cash you find in the game or
you can buy these gems
the real money and right now though
overall there's not a lot of
customization options in there you can't
even create a female character at this
point which they say is coming soon
it's interesting just to you know just
to watch this game unfold from basically
nothing to whatever it might become in
the future but right now it's definitely
not a complete package yeah look I might
stay away from radical high schoolers
just for a little bit see if it gets any
better but in the meantime I also played
this week
Fullmetal Furies which just came out of
early access so this is from the guys
who made rogue legacy selador games this
is not a roguelike though this is a 2d
multiplayer beat em up game and it's
being advertised as a true cooperative
action game it centers around a special
unit of female soldiers in a war-torn
world who are trying to stop another
massive conflict from breaking out by
going after these antagonists called the
Titans and a bunch of different sort of
nice-looking environments so think of
like inglorious basterds if it was just
like way more charming thank you so
there are four classes there's the
fighter the tank the sniper and the
engineer each with their own distinct
personalities and each character has
wildly different attacks and multiple
special attacks and maneuvers that
comment at the cost of a cool-down and
the reason why this is a true
cooperative game is that there is a big
focus on combining your attacks when you
attack an enemy in the air it'll do like
bonus damage but it's hard to execute
that with just one person rather you
need someone to use a special move which
might launch enemies in the air and rely
on teammates to do the follow-up there
are also a number of enemies that will
come up on screen who have different
colored shields and have to be focused
by certain characters unlike a lot of
beat-em-ups it's not just your
run-of-the-mill fight through everything
all the time and there are different
stages where you might need to just
survive or stages which are just story
moments or stages with weird modifiers
like air strikes are hitting you all the
time there's also an upgrade system
where you can level up your characters
throughout the campaign you can earn and
equip new abilities and so on and the
art and the writing are like really
really top-notch now I only managed to
play this first short amount of time and
because I made the grave mistake of
playing it solo
okay I wouldn't recommend this you can
play it solo and the game has tools to
help you play a solo
so you when you do you can pick between
two characters and swap
wean them quickly right that sounds hot
yet still it's really damn hard even
with the choice of two types of ability
there is online matchmaking but
apparently it's in beta and I couldn't
get into a single match like in an hour
so it's 20 bucks on Steam and I'm giving
a kind of conditional recommendation
because I think it's a really great game
it's a really well made game and if you
have pals who are willing to sort of
play with you and also into this kind of
game you should definitely check it out
and play with them alright well
hopefully a few good selections for you
this week whether or not you have
friends do be sure to join us again next
week where we'll have four new games and
let us know if there are any games that
came out in the past week you thought
were great or if there's anything coming
up that you've got your eye on you can
let me know on Twitter I'm at just
McDonald's and I'm as Edmund Tran and
until next time no more games
see you later
[Music]
[Music]